welchen ursprung haben wir menschen und
wo kommen wir her fragen die
existenziell sind und doch bislang in
allen details nicht eindeutig
beantwortet werden können
doch jetzt hat ein deutsches
forschungsteam das erbgut von 2 100
talern genauer analysiert das besondere
bei der individuen sind älter als die
bislang untersuchten neandertaler konnte
dabei eine völlig neue bisher unbekannte
neandertaler populationen aufgespürt
werden klicks um science-fiction hier
gibt es täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen war es der
moderne mensch also der homo sapiens der
die neandertaler verdrängt hat und
letztendlich dafür gesorgt hat dass sich
deren spuren vor etwa 40.000 jahren
verlieren in der fachwelt war man lange
zeit von genau dieser these ausgegangen
doch neueste genomanalysen zeichnen ein
etwas anderes bild von unseren urahnen
sie offenbaren dass auch heute noch
elemente des neandertaler genoms in uns
stecken tatsächlich tragen wir europäer
rund 2% neandertaler dna in uns heißt
also im klartext homo sapiens und homo
neanderthalensis sind nicht nur
aufeinander getroffen sondern sie haben
auch gemeinsam kinder gezeugt demnach
haben die modernen menschen mit den
neandertalern zusammengelebt und das
erbgut hat sich vermischt klar ist dass
die neandertaler bei diesen
gemeinschaften in der unterzahl waren
doch wie wurde dieses zusammenleben
gestaltet handelte sich vielleicht gar
nicht um sich schafft eine wand stance
und was genau führt letztendlich zu dem
verschwinden unserer steinzeit grundsatz
dazu gibt es viele verschiedene theorien
wurden sie doch von unseren vorfahren
ausgerottet oder war eine massen
epidemie der grund für ihr verschwinden
auch ein klimawechsel wird manchmal als
eine mögliche ursache genannt kreis nur
dass ihr verschwinden
zeitgleich mit der ankunft des modernen
menschen dem homo sapiens auf dem
kontinent zusammenfiel fachleute gehen
zudem davon aus dass die neandertaler
zwar nicht mit einem schlag ausgestorben
sind dies jedoch innerhalb einer relativ
kurzen zeitspanne von etwa 10.000 jahren
weniger passiert erst vor kurzem hatten
wir hier bei pixum zu entwickeln über
eine super spannende neue erkenntnis in
diesem zusammenhang berichtet ein
französisches forschungsteam hatte
damals herausgefunden dass das
aussterben dieser gattung dadurch
begründet sein könnte dass die
fruchtbarkeitsrate bei den jungen
neandertalerin über mehrere tausend
jahre hinweg leicht zurückgegangen ist
laut der fachleute passt dieser
erklärungsansatz zudem relativ kurzen
zeitraum ihres aussterbens demnach sei
der rückgang der fruchtbarkeitsrate zwar
sehr gering aber erreicht über einen
langen zeitraum um den neandertaler
aussterben zu lassen so die studie
aus dem sommer 2009 10 die fachleute
spekulieren ob dabei indirekt auch die
ankunft der homo sapiens eine rolle
gespielt haben könnte
denkbar sei es beispielsweise dass
unsere vorfahren konkurrenten bei der
nahrungssuche gewesen sein
die aufnahme von weniger kalorien kann
nämlich negative einflüsse auf
schwangerschaft namen man mag es kaum
glauben aber trotz jahrelanger und
intensiver forschung ist nicht nur das
ende der neandertaler ein riesiges
rätsel sondern auch deren anfang doch
jetzt hat eine forschungsgruppe vom max
planck institut für evolutionäre
anthropologie in leipzig spannende
erkenntnisse zu unseren steinzeit
cousins gewinnen können die dna analyse
von zwei sehr alten neandertalerknochen
ähnlich hinweise auf eine bisher
unbekannte population die vielleicht
sogar mit dem modernen menschen verwandt
ist und noch mehr
die neue studie hilft auch dabei den
neandertaler als spezies zu beginn
seiner entwicklung zu identifizieren
denn das ist alles andere als einfach
der grund der neandertaler ist
unmittelbar aus dem homo heidelbergensis
seine vorfahren hervorgegangen doch die
genaue grenze liegen hier zwischen
diesen beiden lässt sich kaum ziehen
die ältesten funde die sich eindeutig
als klassischer neandertaler
identifizieren lassen sind zwischen
120.000 und 130000 jahren alt das
forschungsteam aus leipzig hat sie jetzt
das erbgut dieser sehr alten der andere
thaler vorgenommen und zwar anhand der
dna von zwei verschiedenen individuen
zum einen haben die fachleute zellkern
dna aus dem oberschenkelknochen eines
männlichen jahrhundert als analysiert
dieser wurde 1937 in der hohenstein
stadel höhle in baden
merck aufgespürt geben so kümmerten sich
die fachleute um den oberkiefer knochen
eines neandertaler mädchens das 1993 in
belgien gefunden wurde sind älter als
die meisten anderen neandertaler die
forschungsteams weltweit bislang
untersucht haben die beiden vertreter
dieser sehr alten neandertaler lebten
vor etwa 120 tausend jahren und das
ergebnis ist nicht nur eindeutig sondern
auch überraschend denn diese frühen
vertreter der neandertaler aus
westeuropa sind nämlich keineswegs eng
mit den neandertalern verband die zur
selben zeit in sibirien lebten viel
enger sind die beiden westeuropäischen
neandertaler mit den letzten vertretern
ihrer spezies war man die rund 80.000
jahre später in derselben region wie sie
lebten dazu kein prüfer der an der
studie beteiligt war das ergebnis ist
wirklich außergewöhnlich und steht in
starkem kontrast zu der turbulenten
evolutionsgeschichte des modernen
menschen die durch austausch vermischung
und aussterben von populationen geprägt
ist nach ansicht der fachleute legen die
neuen ergebnisse nahe dass die
neandertaler dv rund 120000 jahren in
sibirien gelebt haben später dann durch
eine europäische gruppe ersetzt worden
es zudem vermutet dass experten dem dass
es einen bislang unbekannte population
an neandertalern gegeben haben könnte
früher europäische neandertaler könnten
von diesen dna geerbt haben
denn diese dna analyse offenbarte dass
ich das mitochondriale erbgut des
neandertalers aus der höhle in baden
württemberg deutlich von dem erbgut der
spätere neandertaler aus derselben
region unterscheidet ganz anders also
als das analysierte erbgut aus dem
zellkern kurzem verständnis das
mitochondriale erbgut vererbt sich
mütterlicherseits
hinzu kommt dass andere forschungsteams
bereits vor einiger zeit rund 70
mutationen aufspüren konnten diese
unterstreichen die unterschiede zu
bekannten mitochondrialen genomen
anderer neandertaler
dazu heißt es in der studie bei dieser
unbekannte population könnte es sich
entweder um eine isolierte neandertaler
population handeln die noch nicht
entdeckt wurde
oder sie könnte von einer potenziell
größeren population aus afrika stammen
die mit dem modernen menschen verwandt
ist die neue studie liefert also nicht
nur spannende erkenntnisse
dann wird gleichzeitig auch neue fragen
auf es bleibt also spannend ungelöstes
rätsel wie starben die neandertaler aus
anklicken anschauen und klicks und
science fiction abonnieren und nicht die
glocke vergessen
falls euch wissenschaft interessiert
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran